Donald Trump is a chameleon,
not just because he morphed
from liberal to conservative
faster than you can say
Koch brothers, but...
he looks like a lot of things.
Reddit thought his hair looked
like this caterpillar.
-Uh...
-(laughter)
Also deadly.
BuzzFeed thought he looked
like this sushi... right here.
(laughter, applause)
And...
I feel bad for the sushi.
That's really...
-unfair.
-Uncanny.
On this program, admittedly,
we've said that he looks like
everything from a corn husk
cursed by a witch
to a dissonant bagpipe
powered by farts, but...
-(laughter) -the Internet
has found a new thing
that resembles The Donald,
and it is wonderful.
Comedians,
what looks like Mr. Trump?
Is it a...
Doug Benson.
(laughter)
-(cheering)
-A really... dank...
SANDERS:
I think they know you, Doug.
HARDWICK:
...weed nugget.
I'm not gonna fall for that.
(laughter)
It's A) A weasel-like Pokémon.
Yes! That's the correct answer!
Take a look. There it is.
(cheering, applause)
-OAKERSON: Good grab.
-This, uh...
(cheering continues)
This angry weasel
with the tiny hands
and the bad hair
looks just like Donald Trump.
This is Yungoos. Yungoos.
And just like in Pokémon,
Trump wants to catch 'em all!
He just means foreigners.
-Uh...
-(audience groaning)
Hey, man,
I didn't (bleep) do it.
-Uh...
-(laughter)
Pokémon are known for attacks
like Blaze Kick and Comet Punch,
so, comedians,
now that PokéDon is here,
what's one
of his special attacks?
Big Jay.
How about the Immigrant Launch?
-(laughter)
-All right, points. Yeah. Yeah.
-Vance.
-Man Tan Splaining Spray.
-Yeah, all right.
-(laughter)
Doug.
-Tiny Hand Slap.
-(laughter)
All right.
-Points.
-(applause)
Ow. Stop it!
Stop it! Stop it!